condemnation and support has followed
India surprised move to revoke special
status for the disputed region of
Kashmir under its control India on
Monday did away with a constitutional
provision that allowed indian-controlled
Kashmir to frame a majority of its own
laws neighboring Pakistan has called the
move illegal and there have been anti
India protests across the country
a joint shooting of both houses of
parliament was also convened to discuss
the situation arising out of the move
the issue figure in India's lower house
of parliament on Tuesday as well but a
day after India's Home Minister Amit
Shah announced the move his statement
has generated a storm of responses the
presidential order on article 370 by the
Modi government is basically a
constitutional coup this is an attack on
the Constitution and you cannot decide
anything without Pakistan women vote
along with the Kashmiris so Pakistan
will do everything whether its command
to ensure that this wrong is Kashmir is
under curfew three former Chief
Minister's and other party leaders or
all under house arrest and across the
state the atmosphere resembles a war
like situation India dares to try any
mischief in azad kashmir
every man woman and child will stand up
with Pakistan's Armed Forces so God
willing we'll make a cemetery for the
Indian soldiers inside Kashmir in India
however there have been celebrations in
many parts of the country supporters of
the Hindu nationalist BJP government of
Prime Minister Narendra Modi rejoiced
after the move was announced many have
called it the day of court actual
independence for India in reference to
Indian constitutional law now being
fully valid in the disputed territory
supporters have also taken to social
media including the Indian Prime
Minister Narendra Modi he praised his
Home Minister speech at Parliament
tweeting that it accurately highlighted
the monumental in justices of the
and coherently presented our vision for
the sisters and brothers of Jammu and
Kashmir and this from former Indian Army
Major God of area are responding to
claim that scrapping article 370 had
grave implications to national security
for 72 years tens of thousands have died
in Kashmir and fought three wars what
can be graver than this and amid the
massive security crackdown on Kashmir
Bollywood actor Anupam Kher came out
with this controversial tweet kashmir
solution has begun and joining me now is
Haris colleague he's secretary-general
of the Human Rights Commission of
Pakistan mr. colleague thank you so much
for making the time what is your
reaction to the move of the Indian
government thank you very much I think
it has created a lot of unrest in
Pakistan as well and there's a there's a
kind of of allah of a broad consensus
between the peace mongers the peaceniks
and people who have been more hawkish in
the past there's a broad consensus among
all of them that this the surprise move
I mean it is it is a surprise move to an
extent although it was being prepared by
mr. Modi's government for quite some
time I mean the you know they were they
were working in that direction but it is
a bit of a surprise move and it is it is
being condemned and the revocation of
article 370 and you know the subsequent
35 a you know it's it's being seen as
something that is going to unsettle the
region and bring more suffering on on
the citizens of Kashmir on or you know
on both sides of the border because
people living on you know across the
line of control you know Dave if there
is if there is a conflict if there is
more violent protests right it is all
going to I mean people ask you to suffer
now the Human Rights Commission of
Pakistan India the the Human Rights
Commission of Pakistan of you of the of
which was attracted to general tweeted
earlier that it was a breach of trust
why is it a beach breach of
trust you see the thing is that I don't
know if the pre Human Rights Commission
of Pakistan came out with a statement
yesterday which is very clear about the
revocation and escalation of tensions
between the new countries because we are
concerned with the violations of human
rights in Pakistan particularly that is
a part of our mandate but there is a
fallout of something that happens in
Kashmir so automatically we get dragged
into commenting on what India does in
Kashmir also but it's it is you know
there are things which have to be which
have to be settled within the
constitutional and bilateral agreements
that we have made and the constitutional
framework of India as well so I think
there is a problem which which your
opposition the opposition not your
opposition the Indian opposition is
actually is also raising there's these
steps are against the Indian
Constitution and the Instrument of
Accession
that the Maharaja is saying with with
with deney so so I think there is a
breach of trust of of your Kashmir
citizens and you can see when 50 for
instance saying that you know it was a
wrong decision on their part to keep
canvassing english-made for continuing
to stay with DeLeon and work with India
you know so I think that's that's quite
reflective of of how Kashmiri think
across different party party divides now
you've written about the situation in
Kashmir quite a bit you are a poet and
you have connections to the region do
you think in this revised atmosphere
that exists as a result of the
revocation of article 370 they can at
all be peace between India and Pakistan
or for that matter
some element of calm in Kashmir you see
it is it is not just a disputed
territory I mean it is about people I
mean any any solution that we need to
seek both India and Pakistan
has to be people center and
unfortunately if India continues to see
it as a territory or Pakistan sees it as
a territory that that it has claims on I
think that is not going to resolve the
situation Kashmir is have to play a
central role they have to be put in the
center of any solution that these two
countries seek so it is not just a
disputed territory but also people
should actually be as I said should be
consulted Kashmiri it is about kashmiris
first and and as far as you know there
is there is a delta of escalating
escalation of tensions and that
resulting because there has been a heavy
or you know shelling across the line of
control that we have observed over the
past few days and that can escalate any
time so so I you know it is it is
actually undermining the the rights of
the Kashmiri citizens when you turn it
on to an issue on a piece of land
between two countries right Haris
colleague will have to leave it there
for the time being but I'm sure we'll be
speaking again very soon thank you so
much for your time thank you